Mark Zuckerberg mr. Facebook you mighta
saw this last week he is very white he's
extremely white uh so he and three or
two of his other billionaire co founders
of facebook you know much they made on
one day on Facebook last week 4.5
billion dollars yeah 4.5 billion dollars
so this is one day last week Zuckerberg
gained 3.2 billion himself elevating his
fortune to twenty seven point four
billion uh he added 12.4 billion to his
net worth last year Dustin Moskowitz co
founder of Facebook gained nine hundred
forty million he's the youngest
billionaire on earth I like we put on
earth there uh Mars holy situation and a
29 years old uh is eight days younger
than Zuckerberg and Sheryl Sandberg
Facebook COO became one of the world's
youngest female billionaires just a
couple other numbers for you Facebook
rose 14.1 percent the stock that is 261
dollars and eight cents and this file
quarterly results where the revenue rose
30 sixty-three percent to 2.5 nine
billion of corsica brick has donated a
lot of money just own it a billion
dollars Silicon Valley communication
foundation there put computers and
things so they can watch us all the time
and all that kinda stuff okay should we
be angry at these people that not not
the one percent of we've talked a lot
about on the show that the one percent
is something like three hundred thousand
dollars so it's not the one percent but
should we be a little annoyed at the
save point ooo 1% the guys the billions
the billions of do and what are some one
that said that he has more wealth than
anyone could know what to do in one
lifetime wasn't there I'll say I said
that yeah what can you do with all that
money I mean even if he does good stuff
with all this money I'm not besmirching
the good name of Mark Zuckerberg but
even if he's doing good stuff with it
it's too much right like how do we
decide what's too much I don't give me
an answer the answer by economic God we
don't I mean people are able to make
money he wasn't some person look you
could say that he had some came from
some sort of elite privileged people can
argue that just by saying that he was a
white male at
private school he went to Harvard data
but the thing is look he's a self-made
person who had an incredible idea that
he saw through from beginning to end and
then he got everybody in America then
everybody in the world on board so he's
being rewarded and we can say is the
reward fair as a person who is trying to
find a cure for cancer or someone
teaching children are they worth more
than someone who invented Facebook and
in this country and in this world yes
they are yeah everyone's on facebook
it's something we all use they've
managed to mine all of our information
and advertise to us and and they're
doing a lot more things that are going
to creepy and weird in order to make
this money but that's kind of when you
see that's when you see get more
involved once too in order to go from
something that makes millions and
millions of dollars you need to be
invested into something that's kind of
shifting the game or shifting people's
perceptions or manipulating the people
using your product and that's where he's
gone with it so that's why he is all the
money so again the only way to shut down
somebody making a gazillion dollars is
by people saying that on his facebook
anymore but who was gonna regulate it
like the government right and believe me
I'm on board that libertarian strain of
like he built it like it's his let him
do it but there it seems to me we have
this such an income inequality thing
right now and Obama's making that you
know what he says is going to be like
the last three years of his presidency
and all that that we're gonna I feel
like we're gonna start having riots on
the streets when people really figure
out a graduation yeah yeah well look
Zuckerberg represents what people want
the reason why people don't ride is the
idea that some day they'll be part of
the one percent the reason why most
people aren't angry with the one percent
is because in their head they imagine
that it's only a few years or that one
bright idea till to become part of it so
that's why yeah doesn't the Facebook
thing hafta burst because we've also
talked about that a lot here that there
is definitely a fatigue with this
thought I was gonna burst yeah I went
one of the public and now they're
financed all these you know new ways
because if we're always on mobile now
yeah there's new ways of advertising
find out where you are and when you're
there and advertising specifically for
you that was I think why they got
whether revenue went up so much as their
advertising dollars are huge because of
the mobile content right well their
facebook paper also now exactly right
now they have all the journalists
knowing and all the big news companies
knowing that they can kind of sort and
sift through what Facebook decides to
show to people so now Facebook's
controlling the information that a
certain demographic of people received a
lot of people
he's gone that'll also be doing yeah
we're gonna talk more about net
neutrality we did it last week but that
that's a whole other whole thing so do
you think that the the NSA stuff and the
spying stuff and the privacy stuff maybe
we'll sort of begin the ending of
Facebook that maybe we're finally
getting to the point where we don't want
to share everything and we feel like we
don't know what we're sharing so maybe
singing from any seeing it and who's
using it in Facebook's closed government
and all kind of stuff that maybe people
will pull back and then ultimately get
off facebook I don't know in such a
celebrity culture and I think that
Facebook is a way for your common person
to become their own celebrity you know
they're able to post and show their life
and i think that the culture we live in
kind of don't see almost eight dictates
but kind of feeds into that facebook
mentality and the twitter mentality and
the Instagram mentality of look at me
look where I am suppose you know and and
advertisers as well as find that if if
our eyes are their advertisers will go
where the eyes are ya remember that film
that in a kind of film a day without a
mexican i think it was our day without
mexicans somebody made this great film
where they were like what if all the
illegal immigrants and mexicans doing
that work just disappeared from earth
what would people rely on would it be
like the apocalypse in california and
other states that rely on it really they
should do a movie like you know a day
without facebook and just watch everyone
logs off of facebook and see if the
world just crumbles I'm serious choking
which everyone to me I will occur there
showed how isolated our world can become
a more all focused on you know thinking
we're connecting everybody but we're
just stuck in this little isolated
insular world all right well maybe we
can start a trend right here I actually
like that idea can we do a day with no
social media i will put down twitter for
a day if you guys are into it comment
down below and that maybe we'll maybe
we'll start a trend what would the
hashtag be um no social media don't
worry
god she's good you should be an
advertiser